i
llega o crearía la asistencia militar de
eeuu en medio de los temores ante una
eventual invasión de rusia soldados
estadounidenses también empiezan a
aterrizar en polonia como parte del
esfuerzo de la otan mientras tanto
bombarderos rusos con capacidad nuclear
sobrevolaron de largos
costa rica se alista para las elecciones
de este domingo más de 3 millones de
personas están llamadas a elegir a su
nuevo presidente en medio de un complejo
panorama electoral con 25 candidatos lo
que genera indecisión entre los votantes
tenemos análisis
sin vida fue hallado ryan hauran el niño
de 5 años que cayó a un pozo de 32
metros de profundidad el pasado martes
en marruecos la operación que captó la
atención internacional se extendió
durante 5 días y se vio retrasada por
temores a deslizamientos de tierra
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos hablando de la
atención en europa del este debido a los
temores de una eventual invasión de
rusia a ucrania este sábado arribaron a
polonia un grupo de altos oficiales de
las fuerzas armadas de eeuu para
reforzar la otan se espera que lleguen
unos 3.000 efectivos estadounidenses
pertenecientes a la 82 brigada
aerotransportada rafael pérez nos cuenta
más
comenzó el refuerzo oriental de la otan
esta mañana una avioneta aterrizó en el
sur de polonia con un grupo de altos
mandos militares estadounidenses el
arribo de los oficiales no identificados
forma parte del contingente de 3.000
soldados pertenecientes a la 82 brigada
aerotransportada de los eeuu que
permanecerán temporalmente en la nación
europea por orden del presidente joe
biden comienza por chips este apoyo que
nos llega es también un signo de
solidaridad aliada y muestra de que
juntos somos más fuertes podemos confiar
unos en otros cerca de allí se preparan
las condiciones logísticas para el
alojamiento de los efectivos quienes
están arribando desde el viernes en la
noche
la presencia estadounidense divide la
opinión de los residentes en la zona
en general estoy en contra de que
polonia interfiera en los asuntos de
ucrania todo es humo y espejos es todo
pero creo que es una buena medida creo
que todavía no hay suficientes tropas y
debemos esforzarnos por reunir más en
este contexto las maniobras militares no
cesan este sábado la flota del pacífico
rusa realizó ejercicios en el estrecho
de la perú próximo al mar de japón al
tiempo que dos bombarderos estratégicos
sobrevolaron belarús
mientras la guardia nacional de ucrania
desarrolló maniobras entre los edificios
abandonados de la zona de exclusión de
chernóbil cerca de la frontera
bielorrusa y a poco más de 130
kilómetros de kiev la capital de ucrania
costa rica elegirá a su próximo gobierno
este domingo 6 de febrero y son 25 los
aspirantes presidenciales una cifra
récord en la historia del país sin
embargo sólo tres de los candidatos son
favoritos y representan la derecha
conservadora la tendencia de
centroderecha y las al demócrata nuestra
corresponsal sinde y regidor nos cuenta
quiénes son
fabricio alvarado el líder como se hace
llamar en esta campaña presidencial es
el candidato de derecha conservadora del
recién creado partido nueva república
periodista ex diputado salmista
evangélico y polémico por su empatía con
jair bolsonaro vuelve a la contienda por
segunda vez en la elección pasada su
rechazo al matrimonio igualitario no lo
benefició esta vez no habla del tema y
se centra en otras propuestas generar
empleo reactivar la economía sin más
impuestos bajar impuestos y lograr
captar recursos mediante otras
propuestas que no sean más impuestos
lynette saborío ex vicepresidenta de la
república también arrastra la intención
de voto del partido de centroderecha
unidad social cristiana la abogada fue
directora del organismo de investigación
judicial ministra de presidencia y de
planificación le han señalado de poseer
un discurso ambiguo en esta campaña yo
creo que si hay algo que me mueve es
sentir que podemos hacer
transformaciones para lograr una
justicia social mayor jose maria
figueres de liberación nacional es el
más veterano en ésta ya estuvo en la
silla presidencial a finales de los 90
este empresario de tendencia
socialdemócrata lidera las encuestas por
el legado de su padre que fue el
presidente que abolió el ejército sus
detractores le señalan una supuesta
falta de ética en casos de corrupción en
el pasado se han levantado muchos falsos
que en toda la historia de este país
nunca fiscal alguno ha llamado ojos de
maría figueres para cuestionarlo tan
siquiera sobre ningún caso a pesar de
que la intención de votos se centra en
tres candidatos de los 25 inscritos los
costarricenses que irán a las urnas se
inclinarán hacia un presidente que
resuelva los problemas económicos que
dejó la pandemia sin embargo más del 30
por ciento del electorado está indeciso
con las opciones a pocas horas de la
votación por lo que una segunda ronda
para abril próximo parece inminente en
brásil cientos de personas salieron a
las calles del río de janeiro para pedir
justicia por el joven congoleño que
murió la semana pasada tras recibir una
fuerte paliza portando carteles y
entonando arengas los manifestantes
rechazaron el racismo y la xenofobia los
detalles desde el río de janeiro con
nuestra corresponsal valeria saccone
por la música de la pac o era la ciudad
de río de janeiro brotes
con refugiados congoleños de 24 años
estrella de la violencia de su país hace
8 años y que encontró la muerte en la
playa de barra uno de los lugares más
ricos de la ciudad sólo porque estaba
pidiendo que le pagasen dos días de
trabajo 200 reales lo que equivale a 37
dólares
[Aplausos]
gracias a todos ustedes gracias por el
amor que están demostrando por móvil
solo queremos pedir justicia hasta el
final hasta el final
infelizmente nombras
lamentablemente existe un racismo
estructural el racismo que nosotros como
pueblo negro experimentamos todos los
días con miedo de morir de salir de casa
y no volver a casa
estamos viviendo el momento del triste
esta ciudad no merecía estar en las
noticias por causa de tanta violencia
ella siempre fue un lugar de alegría y
acogían de alegría y de alimento
no
viento de río de janeiro anunciado hoy
que transformará este kiosco donde el
moisés cohen brutalmente asesinado en un
memorial dedicado a la cultura congoleña
y africana además van a ofrecer la
gestión del kiosco a sus familiares
somos formas de compensación por la
pérdida de su familiar querido pasamos a
marruecos donde se confirmó que ryan
aura en el pequeño de cinco años que
había caído a un pozo de 32 metros de
profundidad desde el pasado martes fue
encontrado sin vida la noticia de su
fallecimiento fue dada a conocer a
través de un comunicado del rey mohamed
sexto quien expresó sus condolencias a
los familiares la operación de rescate
en el pueblo de israel ubicado en la
provincia de chachachá wen se extendió
durante cinco días y se vio retrasada
debido a los temores por eventuales
deslizamientos de tierra al menor se le
había estado suministrando agua comida y
oxígeno ampliación de esta noticia desde
marraquech con nuestra corresponsal
sofía catalán
todo marruecos y gran parte del mundo
lleva días conmocionado con el caso del
niño rayán hoy en los servicios de
rescate han de marruecos han sacado el
cuerpo de este niño sin vida del pozo al
que cayó el pasado martes en la
localidad del grama en chefchauen en el
norte del país y cayó en este pozo a 32
metros de profundidad el niño tenía 5
años y como decimos ha sido encontrado
sin vida los servicios de emergencias
han trasladado su cuerpo al hospital y
hasta el momento se desconocen más
detalles para intentar sacar al niño y
han trabajado durante la cantidad de
días pues muchos cuerpos especiales del
país para poderlos sacar tuvieron que
cavar primero un túnel paralelo en
vertical al pozo donde estaba el niño y
después para poder acceder a la posición
estaba en otro túnel horizontal los
trabajos han sido de alta dificultad
pues dadas las condiciones del té hoy
también se han demorado más tiempo
deseado porque ha habido diferentes
derrumbes como decimos finalmente hoy
los servicios de rescate han sacado a
este niño de 5 años del pozo al que cayó
el pasado martes a 32 metros de
profundidad y desgraciadamente lo han
sacado sin vida hasta que está
informativa en france 24 pero los
invitamos a visitar nuestra página web
www punto frente 4 punto com para seguir
la actualización de nuestras noticias
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]